JOHN, THANKS SO MUCH FOR THE
TIME.
>> THANKS, BRET.
>> Melissa: FOX NEWS ALERT.
MORE PROTESTS IN JERUSALEM
CALLING FOR ISRAELI PRIME
MINISTER BENJAMIN NETANYAHU TO
RESIGN.
THERE HAVE BEEN FIVE
DEMONSTRATIONS IN THE LAST WEEK.
ANOTHER ONE IS SCHEDULED FOR
TONIGHT.
IN FRONT OF THE PRIME MINISTER’S
HOME.
TRAY YINGST IS THERE NOW AND
JOINS US LIVE.
>> THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE ARE
EXPECTED TO GATHER THIS EVENING
IN JERUSALEM IN FRONT OF THE
HOUSE OF ISRAELI PRIME MINISTER
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU.
MANY ISRAELIS HAVE JOINED UP.
POLICE ARE TRYING TO SEPARATE
THE TWO SIDES.
THE PEOPLE WE ARE LOOKING AT NOW
ARE AGAINST THE ISRAELI PRIME
MINISTER AND FRUSTRATED ABOUT
THE GOVERNMENT’S HANDLING OF THE
COVID-19 OUTBREAK.
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE
LOCATION WE ARE STANDING,
PRO-ISRAELI PRIME MINISTER
BENJAMIN NETANYAHU PROTESTERS AT
THIS SITE.
AT LEAST 34 PEOPLE WERE ARRESTED
IN SIMILAR PROTESTS AND CLASHES.
MORE THAN 20% OF ISRAELIS ARE
CURRENTLY UNEMPLOYED NOW AS A
RESULT OF THE ECONOMIC FALLOUT
FROM CORONAVIRUS AND THE PRIME
MINISTER HAS BEEN HEAVILY
CRITICIZED FOR NOT COMING UP
WITH A BETTER PLAN TO HELP THOSE
OUT OF A JOB, SUCCESSFULLY
LOCKED DOWN AND BEAT THE FIRST
WAVE OF COVID-19 BEFORE RAPIDLY
REOPENING SCHOOLS AND
BUSINESSES.
THIS LED THE COUNTRY INTO A FAR
WORSE SECOND WAVE THAT HAS SEEN
MORE THAN 50,000 CASES OF
COVID-19, OVERNIGHT THE PRIME
MINISTER DID APPOINT A CZAR THE
C.E.O. OF ONE OF THE HOSPITALS
BUT THIS IS NOT CALMING TENSION
HERE.
WE SAW THIS MORNING A TWEET FROM
ISRAEL’S PRESIDENT CALLING ON
ALL PARTIES WITHIN THE
GOVERNMENT TO COME TOGETHER AND
CUT IT OUT.
HE SAID THAT THERE IS NO PLAN
CURRENTLY AND AS CASES FOR
COVID-19 CONTINUE TO RISE HERE
IN ISRAEL YOU CAN SENSE THE
FRUSTRATION OUTSIDE OF THE PRIME
MINISTER’S HOUSE.
POLICE TONIGHT HOPING THIS